we have seen you guys discussing a move
to the farm and i know there's been
debates whether
that's the right move literally for your
family
have you guys made a decision yet
there's a lot of moving parts and a lot
of
family and emotions and expectations
we have another season of little people
big
world hey
hey hi
tori what are you doing here i don't
know what i'm doing here i'm
toys destroyed i'm freeloading and
distracting everyone
yeah that's exactly what she's doing i'm
just here until like people start
showing up then we'll probably head out
what
have you been the most excited for that
fans have been
seeing and will continue to see play out
this season
i think so yeah i'm super excited seeing
jackson and lilac kind of grow up has
been
really fun as parents for us um
for me that's like one of my favorite
parts of watching the whole show is
watching them and they're funny
nisms or whatever they do um their isms
yeah that's been a huge part of it uh
jackson may do a little camping trip at
the very end of the season
that's probably for me a highlight of
this last six months
um which was a lot of fun and um yeah
that's what i'm kind of looking forward
to
yeah do the kids understand yet
that like they are reality tv
personalities definitely not
no they they definitely like it's i
think it's funny because
you know living in the 21st century i
feel like all kids see themselves
on like a phone or like sometimes you
know
wherever they see themselves being
recorded so
you know honestly i don't think it's
much different to him he asks
he calls it his show and he asks you to
watch it his favorite show
is his show he knows every character he
knows
you know so it's kind of fun for him to
watch and we don't we don't watch all of
it with him but like
he gets a trip when it's you know him
and his sister and mom and dad
i feel i feel a spin-off coming one day
for our deer
he can get his own show just we'll just
have like
45 minutes of just jackson i feel like
that would be the the best
scenario i mean honestly the content we
all deserve
oh well speaking of content this season
so far we have seen you guys
discussing a move to the farm and i know
there's been debates whether
that's the right move literally for your
family
have you guys made a decision yet no no
no decision yet um
yeah we haven't made a decision yeah
there's a lot of moving parts and a lot
of
family and emotions and expectations so
i haven't made that decision yet we're
kind of settled where we're at and we're
very content here
um that was on the table for a minute
there
just was like the pandemic though too i
feel like everything kind of got
put on hold and yeah moving to the farm
is no exception to that
totally understandable i mean the
pandemic has uh
thrown a wrench in a lot of things this
past year but um
we are going to see this season you two
celebrating the 10 year anniversary of
your first date which is crazy when you
hear those words
10 year anniversary what comes to mind
uh yeah it's 10-year anniversary i love
it i love that stuff crazy how fast it
goes
yeah it's just crazy looking back 10
years
um only been married for five so like
and we know six
next month or six next month yeah that's
the thing about the pandemic it's gone
so fast like
i turned 30 in the panama and 31 like
two birthdays jackson was
two when this all started he's now four
you know so yeah so yes we're on our six
year anniversary coming up here
you know how they say like when you know
you know was it like that for you guys
at the beginning
it was for me yeah yeah i think that
exact took some people
it wasn't like convincing it was just i
was like i never dated i never
like she was my first kiss like it was i
was focused on soccer and like
so i'm like all right i guess i'll like
let me see
let's see what this is all about dating
and then yeah then i was like all right
one and done was there a moment did you
end up having a moment later on where
you're like
okay this is the one yeah i
yeah my moment was more yeah just yeah
like i love
tori and yeah it was solid
i guess yes yeah
here we are a decade later which is
amazing congratulations to you guys the
decade together
six years married two kids what would
you guys say
the secret is to your relationship oh
toward me i feel like we're both pretty
good communicators um
i think reflection too is a huge one
yeah we reflect a lot together
we have same similar areas too like
we're different in a lot of ways but
then also like there's some
there's a lot of similarities too like
core foundational
like personalities are pretty yeah we
just see things a lot eye to eye
like the same things like to do the same
things and just have fun don't take life
too seriously
and just have fun well they say what
marry your best friend
yes that's good yeah
well you guys do have such a beautiful
family and i loved the post that you
guys recently made on social media of
jackson
uh being done with preschool which is
crazy where has the time gone but
how how do you love it he loves school
right he loves school he goes
yeah he went two days a week he only
went two days a week and he
i think every morning would ask like can
i go to school today
like the only one yeah he loved it
yeah first experience in school so
he he was pretty excited about it he had
you know
his best friend is in his class and his
teacher was fantastic so yeah
it was nice that's great to hear what
are your guys's summer plans with the
whole fam
uh we got a sun river a central oregon
trip coming up here
um we're gonna start getting pretty
like closer to home than maybe we do in
most summers this year like
we're hoping to take little we live an
hour and a half of the beach
in an hour and a half from the mountains
so we'll probably just take
day trips little trips here and there
yeah we just did arizona
um so yeah not not too many plans this
summer
a lot of family time though i and also
maybe a a wedding coming up for your mom
i like that yeah yeah a lot of family
time yeah my mom's getting married in
august here
um i guess i don't look at that as like
a trip or anything
but yeah plan um so yeah she'll be
getting married here in the end of
august
um so yeah i'm sure that'll consume a
lot of the that month
i love it will that wedding be televised
have they decided yet
i i think so yeah i think um stay tuned
yeah stay tuned but they're pretty
everyone's pretty excited for it i know
we've all been there every step of the
way it's like okay we got it
we gotta see the actual wedding now yeah
i think everyone's pretty excited about
that so
i'm yeah it's gonna be fun how great
will it be
to have the whole family together to to
celebrate such a joyous
occasion uh yeah no it'll be great
having the whole family
my sister doesn't live in town neither
does my brother my youngest brother
um so yeah everyone will be coming back
into the fold um
and yeah weddings are just fun you see
family like my a lot of my mom's family
don't live here so you'll be seeing
here's his family
yeah never met chris's side of things
family
friends really so um and this is chris's
first wedding too
like this is his you know so you know
it's gonna be exciting for him
like this is his first experience
getting married
um so yeah it's just gonna be fun i
think all around will the kids be
involved i could see little lila being
like a flower girl
maybe yeah also saying you might we
might
you might see more of that you gotta
tune in
i feel like jackson's gonna turn it into
his own thing
honestly though it's gonna be yeah we're
gonna have to reign it in like this is
mimi's day
not yours yeah him and his cousin amber
yeah they both i feel like are going to
do some speech
everyone is here for me
stealing that day that's a really cool
thing for for fans to be able to
be along with you guys for the rides the
highs
the lows everything in between and you
know it made me think about
how there's another royal family on tv
the kardashians who
decided this year was time to call it
quits after
two decades of showing their lives for
everyone to see on
on tv when will you guys know it's time
to rap oh that's i think
like the minute it's not fun anymore i
think for us like we're
we're we enjoy sharing our lives and
you know for for right now our kids
get along great with the crew and it's
fun
and the minute it's not fun anymore i
think that's you know then you kind of
got to come together and be like all
right so what
what's what's our next step i guess